welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM
Quantum this is lesson number 15 of the series and it's the third lesson of the fourth unit which is on Quantum error
correction thus far we've seen a few examples of quantum error correcting codes including the nine Cubit Shore
code the 7 Cubit Steen code and the 5 Cubit code and we've also discussed the stabilizer formalism which provid
provides us with a mathematical Foundation from which we can describe and analyze these and many other Quantum error correcting
codes the codes that I just mentioned are undoubtedly interesting and they represent a natural place to begin an
exploration of quantum error correction the problem is that they can only tolerate a very low error rate
correcting an error on one cubit out of five seven or nine isn't bad but in all likelihood at least as far as we suspect
we're going to need to be able to tolerate a lot more errors than that in order to make large-scale Quantum Computing a
reality in this lesson we'll take a first look at some more sophisticated Quantum error correcting code constructions including codes that can
tolerate a much higher error rate than the ones we've seen so far and are viewed as promising candidates for practical Quantum error correction in
actual physical devices here's a brief overview of the lesson we'll begin with a class of
quantum error correcting codes known as CSS codes named for the researchers that first discovered them Robert calderbank Peter
Shaw and Andrew Steen the CSS code construction allows one to take certain pairs of classical
error correcting codes and combine them into a Quantum error correcting code as a part of that discussion we'll
take a pretty quick look at classical linear codes and we'll also talk about some of the basic properties of CSS
codes the second part of the lesson is on a code known know as the Torah code which is a fundamental and really
beautiful example of a Quantum error correcting code that can tolerate a relatively High error rate in fact the
Torah code isn't a single example of a Quantum error correcting code but rather it's an infinite family of codes one for
each positive integer starting from Two and in the last part of the lesson we'll briefly discuss a couple of other
families of quantum codes including surface codes which are closely connected to the torque code as well as
color codes people have been studying classical error correcting codes since the 1940s
and it's a fascinating and Rich subject linear codes are perhaps the simplest type of classical error
correcting code and I'll explain exactly what the word linear means in this context in just a moment but one simple
way to express what they are is that they're stabilizer codes that happen to be classical and we'll see shortly that
CSS codes are basically pairs of classical linear codes that are combined together to create a Quantum error
correcting code so for the sake of that discussion we're going to need to understand a few basic things about
classical linear codes first we're going to take Sigma to be the binary alphabet for this entire
discussion and now when we refer to a classical linear code we mean a set C of binary strings of length n for some
positive integer n satisfying just one basic property which is that if u and v are binary strings in C then the string
uxx ORV is also in C here by the way uxx ORV means the bitwise exclusive or of u and v just
like we saw multiple times back in lesson five and six in the quantum algorithms portion of the series and this is what it means for a
classical code to be linear in essence we're thinking about binary strings of length n as being n-dimensional vectors
where the entries are all either zero or one but instead of ordinary vector addition over the real or complex
numbers we're using addition modulo 2 which is simply the exor so if we have
two code words u and v meaning that u and v are binary strings in C then U plus v modulo 2 or in other words uux or
V must also be a code word in C and by the way this implication has to be true even if U is equal to V nothing rules
out that possibility and that implies that every classical linear code must contain the all zero string because the
bitwise exor of any string with itself is the all zero string for example the three-bit
repetition code is a classical linear code in particular there are two possible choices for U and two possible
choices for V and it's a pretty trivial matter to go through the possible pairs to see that we always get a code word when we take the bitwise
exor here's another example which is called the 743 Hamming code this is one of the very first classical error
correcting codes that was ever discovered and it consists of 16 binary strings of length seven there is a very simple logic
behind the selection of these strings but I won't explain that in this video and I should also mention that you will sometimes see these strings reversed but
for now the main point is that if we take any two of these strings and exor them together we'll get another string in the
code so it's a linear code and the notation 743 in single square brackets means something analogous to the double
square bracket not a I mentioned in the previous lesson for stabilizer codes but here it's for classical linear
codes in particular code words have seven bits There are 16 code words so we can encode four bits using the code and
it happens to be a distance three code meaning that you have to flip at least three bits of any one code word to get a
different code word and that implies that it can correct for up to one bit flip error these are simple examples of
codes but even the example of the 74 three Heming code looks kind of mysterious when we simply list all the code words so we need better ways of
describing classical linear codes and there are two natural ways of doing this one way is to describe classical
linear codes by giving a minimal set of code words that generate the code meaning that by taking all the possible
subsets of these code words and xoring them together we get the entire code and that's expressed in mathematical terms
here on the screen another way to think about this is that we're viewing this code as a Subspace of a vector space and this set
of generators is a basis for that Subspace keeping in mind that this is a vector space where arithmetic is done modulo 2 if we have M generators we're
going to end up with a code having two to the m elements each generator doubles the number of elements in the code and
that's consistent with the fact that classical linear codes over the binary alphabet always include a number of strings that's a power of
two the second natural way to describe a classical linear code is by parity checks specifically this is a minimal
list of binary strings having the same length as the strings in the code such that the strings in the code are precisely the ones whose binary
dotproduct with every one of these parity check strings is zero where the binary do product is simply the ordinary